à la verrière on devrait se diriger vers
un duel à 4 pour ces élections
municipales bonsoir gérard claude morfin
vous êtes bonjour bonsoir vous êtes la
tête de liste de la verrière citoyenne
pour le scrutin je précise que vous êtes
également le président de l'association
citoyenne vous avez été adjointe au
maire premier adjoint de 1983 à 1989
adjoint de 95 à 2001 puis vous avez
siéger dans l'opposition entre 2001 et
2008 à chaque fois avec pierre celle un
cours comme maire pourquoi pourquoi
revenir en politique
vous avez bien réviser votre sujet
pourquoi revenir d'abord parce que je ne
suis jamais parti et que
je suis peut-être un peu addicts du
phénomène parce que je continue à
assister aux conseils municipaux et au
conseil d'agglomération
des éléments qui m'amène à revenir comme
vous dites
ben des faits qui sont qui me gêne un
peu comme notamment la démolition la
destruction du sang choisir du bois de
l'étang
si problèmes de sons c'est peut-être dû
à votre porte
on va vous demander de la grangette dans
votre vie vous l'avez dit pas de
peut-être de couper même on le dit et
dans laurier soucis techniques
on va essayer de régler ça
vous l'avez dit pardon la destruction du
centre de loisirs du bois de l'étang on
va reprendre le cours normal de cette
interview avait été construit entre 1977
et 1983 par des élus socialistes et
communistes qui a été démolie pour des
raisons obscures alors que rien ne
prédispose est ce cet équipement public
à disparaître
un autre point c'est la promotion
immobilière à tout va qui envahit le
quartier du bois de l'étang parce que
il ya autre chose à faire que de
ne pas résister à la motion mobilières
sachant que étant ne l'est pas demandé
mais de protestions architectes et
urbanistes
j'ai un avis forcément sur la question
sur la question d'ailleurs je la trouve
quoi vous êtes gêné un petit peu c'est
l'opacité de l'information communal de
plus en plus qui est qui et qui présente
ici on parle d'urbanisme justement sur
le dossier du bois de l'étang qui est
bien sûr au coeur d'un projet de
rénovation urbaine
vous êtes vous contre une démolition des
bâtiments plutôt pour une rénovation de
ses bâtiments au bord de l'étang c'est
ça écoutez ma spécificité c'est j'ai
habité pendant 18 ans quartier ce qui
n'est pas le cas des trois autres
candidats d'une part et d'autre part il
ya des choses à faire effectivement mais
qui ne sont pas celles là donc
effectivement réhabilitation intérieure
rénovation partielle extérieur à y
planter par exemple centre commercial à
ne pas démolir bien évidemment mais à
restaurer et puis changer des éléments
[Musique]
dur les éléments d'équipement des
bâtiments l'ascenseur colonne sèche qui
ont plus de 50 ans d'âge ou presque et
qui normalement dont la durée de vie de
l'ordre de 30 à 35 ans et sur le dossier
l'urbanisme si on parle aussi d'un autre
grand projet à la verrière c'est ce
projet de gare bécane la zone guerre
bécane qui a été relancé par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
vous voudriez voir construire sur cette
zone moitié moins à moitié moins de
logements qui sont prévus il ya environ
mille logements qui sont prévues sur
place vous voudriez voir plutôt 600 650
logements au maximum c'est ça tiens
comment je le sais mais ça je veux
documente c'est bien là il ya plusieurs
sujets d'importance à sur les six ans
qui viennent
à part celui ci un petit mot quand même
sur le point de lavilledieu dont j'ai
commencé à m'occuper en 1995 devrait
être doublé dont qui relie la verrière
c'est quoi c'est pas c'est pas cette
solution là qu'il faut prendre double et
non en tout cas remplacer le pont
existant et et le doublé oui mais pas
comme celui du pont qui jouent l'air ou
là il ya des erreurs techniques qui
auraient été réalisées après vous avez
les mâles button ou dans le cadre de la
consultation publique je m'étonne que
j'étais porteur d'une alternative pour
passer sous la rn 10 et puis je suis
plutôt avec mes compagnons favorable à
une extension du périmètre qui englobe
le passage souterrain actuelle sur les
voies ferrées et pour revenir sur votre
question je n'aime pas tellement le
terme guerre bécade d'abord parce que
les canes ca quartier en tant que tels
égards c'est plutôt à notre quartier qui
s'appelle l'agio et je pense que
l'histoire a son importance dans la
dénomination des dossiers dont bécane
effectivement il faut que ce soit un
quartier qui soit à l'image des deux
autres existants les trois qu'on a dans
les parcs village et voile et en août à
peu près le même poids de population le
même nombre de logements ça serait une
erreur urbanistique que de vouloir en
faire tout de suite 2000 comme c'était
prévu au départ
ou 1500 comme j'ai entendu parce que la
promotion immobilière il faut lui passer
la main dans le dos mais c'est aussi un
combat c'est pas seulement dire il en
faut six ans il ya aussi les équipements
d'accompagnement scolaire sont
commerciales et là ça nous prenait trop
de temps
juste un mot sur la lys qui est aussi
important qui est une liste vous le
revendiquez ni de droite ni de gauche
c'est l'élément citoyens vous soyez vous
souhaitez mettre en avant ça veut dire
c'est davantage l'engagement citoyen
pour la commune de la verrière qui
compte plus que l'étiquette politique
marie côté il ya 20 ans on s'est lancé
dans ce pari de la réflexion d'une
association citoyenne en été je pense un
peu en avance parce que la verticalité
politique a marqué le pas ces derniers
temps le phénomène des ronds-points a
aussi montré que le citoyen est
important plus que
les lecteurs et comment dire
actuellement la citoyenneté est au
centre des préoccupations c'est les
incivilités c'est le manque de propreté
c'est les difficultés de maintenance de
notre patrimoine mobilier et immobilier
tous ajouté boutabout fait qu' il ya une
prise de conscience citoyenne et je vais
devancé votre question certainement
actuellement nous avons plus de
candidats que de places d'accord sur la
liste est donc comme nous fonctionnons
en termes d'entretien entre la tête de
liste et puis le ou la candidate
les entretiens sont pas tout à fait
terminé mais ne vous inquiétez pas il
ira unie citoyenne déposées en
préfecture ou sous-préfecture je me
souviens plus lesquelles le lieu précis
pour montrer qu'il est autre chose de
possible sur les communes petites comme
la variable avec une spécificité il ya
des référents par quartier au sein de
cette liste vous avez nommé des
référents par carte et c'est c'est un
petit peu l'expérience que j'ai trouvé
dans la drôme avec la commune de
saillant oui effectivement c'est là que
sont apparus des attitudes démocratique
citoyenne et puis j'en ai trouvé
finalement en cherchant un peu un petit
peu partout c'est un phénomène ailleurs
même sur l'agglomération de rêve il ya
des listes qui se réclament de la
citoyenneté et je trouve ça très très
fort très très bien sachant que
l'agglomération vous n'avez pas parlé
mais c'est aussi important pour pour
nous puisque ce sont des élections à la
fois municipal et communautaire on élit
également effectivement des conseillers
communautaires et j'ajoute pour terminer
cette interview que vous avez été
vice-président de ce qu'on appelait à
l'époque la ville nouvelle de saint
quentin en yvelines qui aujourd'hui une
communauté d'agglomération merci gérard
claude morfin est d'être venu en plateau
tête de liste de la verrière citoyenne
pour ces élections et sont également
candidats à la verrière la maire
sortante nelly duthu son actuel premier
adjoint jean yves blessure une autre
liste et également la candidature de
l'élue d'opposition nicolas d'un deal